welcome to this video playing chris d
chess 249 that's a complicated name cat
write the original reti opening the
plate with default this is really them
the most ambitious way to to play as
black and I also played a number of
games with that and especially and in
particular this is the setup i have i
have tried it's a quite quite ok 44 for
both sides actually ok c 6 he probably
wants to play a 5 but ok i can i can
take that came how to i wonder if night
be 3 as an idea maybe it keeps some
pressure on d4 so that f-5e for i have
exactly this kind of play is not easily
possible I wonder maybe this is a good
idea getting rid of the bishop ok and
now night to d2 and maybe initiate the
play on the queenside with be five yeah
okay I don't mind that now be five I
wonder if you go see 595 yeah this was
my idea Ricky doesn't ok well now this
is a very nice bishop and TM is
basically not minding this at all
interesting maybe just a phone yeah why
not yeah I like white ear because the
bishop on g7 is so passive it's just
sitting there to protect its own pawns
and I have basically all pieces gets
towards the Queen side and then be seven
is really a problem light a5 is maybe
yeah now I thought Queen 85 and so what
to see doing after that this is good for
wide hmm ok Quincy 30 brooksie one this
does not really help him and take takes
I am double attacking b7 I just have
look see one here why is he playing for
some some weird sacrifice rook see one
Bishop b3 rooks III know this is not
working so he just gifted me this move
yeah here I thought that night c-4 would
be a would be good still still wonder if
maybe also
I wonder if firm I mean I have stuff two
nights yeah I also have the c-4 night
maybe night b7 is not bad intending I do
that intending to play rook c7 and then
94 again
so she said no
night-night see for how does he
protector tonight designer
hmm maybe I can give this check here on
d6 and then go to see a Down check now
maybe he's winning the paw back at the
end yeah 95 is of course leading into an
opposite colored bishops and game night
a8 king bee area that's probably not
good 94 he will take ya ji need to keep
it simple this is this is not the best
move but it's relatively easy to play at
least know that debt sets we add this
this is winning for white despite
despite opposite colored bishops pretty
sure the yeah this is definitely winning
check it was winning without the blunder
as well it's just too too many ports and
the compact structure black resigns yeah
this was was nice I mean always had some
some play on the queenside maybe yeah he
gifted me some some nice things yeah
this is already quite nice for white but
but giving me the complete tempo is
funny hecker I can also take b7 here by
the way yeah I was just
thinking okay this this is just a free
move and it is but maybe taking on b7
was even stronger yeah and yet it's it's
not clear to me should I just go to see
form or should I enter on b7 iya the
computer does not like 9 p-7 it wants to
play nazi form still it looks like like
okay but maybe you cannot win it yeah
here maybe he black must take on see for
him check just let's just blundered the
pawn which in itself is probably not not
very dramatic but here he of course
needs to defend better and he certainly
can I mean if or here before is just
suicidal and she does not need to do it
he can play a plane all the moves we
should be seven or something this is
just losing straight away maybe g5 is a
bit bit tougher but again you cannot
hold it I don't know why why he did that
I mean even played very quickly but this
end game is just very easily winning
because I i get i get you have three
against one basically if we look at this
and i get all the way here or to age
five and then at the end the pawns will
just roll h 4G 4G five he has no way to
block them the bishop on these three is
also very nicely positioned to to block
the deep horn and g it's covered by you
two so this is an ideal setup at some
yeah he gave away the bishop quickly but
it's it's really not a big difference if
he if you place I know this is this I go
here and then then March the pawns okay
thanks for watching